rookie right hander 24 years old from
bolivar of venezuela luis garcia and in
a game like this he wants to give his
manager less reasons to take him out and
be on the attack eddie rosario leads it
off garcia's 0-2
and that's lifted into right field over
his tucker headlong dive and he makes
the catch heck of a catch by tucker
diving toward the line on a ball that
was sinking quickly and that is out
number one that's how you start a
baseball game steal a base hit maybe two
with that dive in right field toward the
line tucker comes up with the beauty one
out nobody on and here is solaire the
d.h
first punch out for luis garcia two outs
now freddie freeman who slides back a
slot the o2 from garcia swing and a miss
freeman goes down on a change-up away
and the ending is over back-to-back
punch-outs for garcia here's the veteran
left-hander compared to his counterpart
tonight max freed
is excited to get back out there after
his game two start five plus innings six
runs seven hits so altuve is aboard for
michael brantley
jam brantley altuve will
get to second and
safe
at first and freed
max looked like he turned his right
ankle over
to the inside of the foot oh
and then he got stepped right on the
outside of the right ankle it's two on
nobody out and they're not going to
challenge and the one two on the way got
him swinging strike three slider low it
in that fans carlos correa and the
astros now with two men in scoring
position but two outs for julie guriel
what a job by max freed technically max
got himself four outs that inning but it
keeps him off the board scoreless came
into the bottom of the second there's
kyle tucker to lead it off left on left
match up
here's one over the head of freed one
play by swanson with a bare hand for the
out
and we've seen a couple of good
defensive plays one on each side
tucker for the astros and now swanson
robs him of an infield hit
two out of nobody on for jose siri oh
one to series
hit in the air to left field coming in
eddie rosario he's there sounded like he
broke his bat and that died into the
glove of eddie rosario obviously has got
to be a little bit better he's been in a
funk
line drive base hit into right center
field
gets it between correa and altuve and
atlanta has their first face runner
[Applause]
as albies has moved down in the order
and he's on to start the third so we'll
lead off it now a two-out walk and the
batter will be so lair there they go
pitch on the way he attacks and smokes
one to deep left this one's going
supersonic that is out of the ballpark
whoa
over the train tracks it's three-nothing
atlanta
and jory solaire lands the first punch
here in the top of the third inning
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the guy who jorge 48 home runs two
seasons ago
what a pick up he's been jorge dropped
the bat turned to his dugout pounded on
his chest went into his trot you can
take all the time you want when you do
that to a baseball that went an
estimated 446 feet and came off as bad
at 110. get another get another
measuring stick folks baker showing him
the dugout wished he had taken him out
i hit her early east of the mound to get
garcia now it's too late javier comes in
for the astros looking for multiple
innings i'm sure on for the sixth time
so far this postseason and it's going to
be riley here's a 2-2 from javier and
struck him out
on a breaking ball two outs here in the
fourth it'll be up to jack peterson now
to keep it alive
strikes out quick and easy in and good
pitching by javier third time in four
innings that the astros have gotten the
lead off man on freed set at the belt
first pitch alvarez grounds one to
albies the flip out over the first they
got him both
back to back innings turning a double
play and this one goes four
six three two out nobody on
here's one right side
all these two is left what a job by max
freed one down to bring nancy swanson up
to the plate he'll be followed by the
top of the order hands we flew out to
left hit the ball
pretty deep dan's be a rope to deep left
field that one's rising kissing goodbye
a two-run bomb by dansby
and it's five-nothing atlanta on the
strength of two
tape measure shots one from jorge one
from dansby and those are the two men
who hit the big home runs the other
night second home run of this world
series
and there was nothing cheap about it he
went to the fastball and dansby we know
can hit a fastball dansby owns javier
he's bombed him the last two times he's
faced him here comes dusty
five to nothing atlanta blake taylor
left-hander is the fourth pitcher for
the astros making his second appearance
in this world series and here's freddie
with a runner in first and two down 3-1
pitch here
slide into left center field well hit
back at the track it's off the wall
solaire digging around third here he
comes
it's 6-0
as freddie freeman delivers here in the
fifth
up and away and freddie took it the
other way and it like you said it just
missed the yellow line out there right
above the braves bullpen
and solaire with two out running on the
crack of the bats scored easily 10th rbi
the postseason for freddy freeman
hopefully another quick inning here
starting with maldonado who's singled
off of him is last time up 2-2
strike three
five strikeouts for freed against no
walks and he's allowed just three
singles all right crowd wants to see
correa do something
swing and a miss and the ball gets by
darneau he's retrieving it back by the
backstop throw to first got him
inning over that went off the glove of
darno on the swing and miss he had to
chase it to the backstop and made a good
throw to freddy to retire correa
nine outs to get it looks like max freed
is finished for the night six innings no
runs four hits six strikeouts no walks
and just
a brilliant effort here tonight
but it's two and two
hard hit and diving gets up throws and
got him
what a play by bregman still playing
defense down by six
looks like bregman had springs in his
legs the way he dove for that ball
toward the line perfect to yuli guriel
got it online freddy one for three with
an rbi double batch with two down to the
base is empty freeman gives that one a
ride deep central and
that ball is gone
freddie freeman leaves the yard
7-0 atlanta and right on cue freddie
freeman with his fifth home run this
postseason he hit that one out there in
the gas pump third homer of the ball
game for the braves we're in the ninth
and that means will smith tie braves are
three outs away from winning it all and
brantley is aboard to lead off here's
the man of the hour that'd be carlos
correa here's one into right center
field going to get it is duvall one on
one out
here's alvarez
[Applause]
to within one out
of a championship
and the atlanta braves are one out away
from winning the world series here on
the 2nd of november 2021 02 on the way
chopper out to dansby
dansby throws to first base is this
happening it is
the atlanta braves are world champions
the atlanta braves have won the 2021
world series
in six games over the houston astros
pure euphoria down on the field as
they're bouncing all over the infield
and in the booth celebration going on on
the field and folks this is what dreams
are made of
and for the 2021 atlanta braves the
dream has come true
they are world champions in 2021
what an incredible moment and a
wonderful time for all of them michelob
ultra organic seltzer as real as it
tastes